salut et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle astuce du mercredi
aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre à calculer de tête la racine carré d'un nombre
Ne fuyez pas. C'est très simple à faire
la seule chose à avoir, le seul prérequis à avoir c'est de bien connaitre tous ses carrés de 1 à 9
1 au carré 1, 2 au carré 4, 3 au carré 9 , jusqu'à 9 au carré 81
parfois ça nous arrive d'avoir des doutes sur certains carrés comme 8 fois 8 ou 7 fois 7
pour être sûr de bien avoir le carré en tête pour pouvoir le vérifier instantanément
je vous rappelle que j'avais fait une astuce, c'était la vidéo n°27
je vais vous faire une fiche ici
comment extraire une racine carré de tête
c'est tellement facile que je me demande pourquoi on nous apprend pas ça à l'école
bon, vous êtes prêts ? je prends le nombre
4225, et donc notre but c'est d'extraire
la racine de 4225
ça se fait en 2 étapes, la 1ère c'est qu'on
regarde l'unité du nombre, là c'est 5
et on cherche quel carré parmi les nombres de 1 à 9 finit par 5
y en a qu'un seul, c'est 5. 5 fois 5=25 c'est le seul donc je sais que ma racine va finir par
5, là je le note
il suffit juste de le garder dans un coin de sa tête
ensuite, la dizaine on oublie
on s'en occupera pas, jamais que ce soit un nombre à 2 chiffres, à 3 chiffres ou à 4 chiffres, la dizaine
ne nous intéresse jamais. On s'intéresse donc à tout ce qu'il y a avant la dizaine
la centaine et les milliers. Et s'il y a qu'une centaine, on s'intéresse qu'à la centaine
là, c'est 42. On va chercher à l'encadrer, quel est le carré le plus proche en dessous
et quel est le carré le plus proche au dessus
le carré le plus proche en dessous, c'est 6
parce que 6 fois 6 = 36
et le plus proche au dessus, c'est 7
puisque 7 fois 7 = 49
et 42, c'est compris entre 36 et 49
celui du dessous c'est 36
c'est celui qu'est avant 42
donc 36 pour l'avoir c'est 6 fois 6
donc je sais que ma racine va commencer par un 6
et c'est fini. La racine carrée de 4225, c'est 65
c'est aussi simple que ça
y a juste une petite chose à savoir en plus
je vous la dirais juste après je refais un exemple quand même facile
tiens, très facile, 144
unité qui finit par 4, 2 parce que 2 fois 2 =4
la dizaine on s'en occupe jamais
devant il nous reste un 1
le 1, c'et entre le carré de 1, 1 et le carré de 2 4
mais le carré en dessous c'est 1, enfin là pour le coup ça tombe pile-poil
donc on sait que c'est 1, ça fait bien 12, racine carrée de 144, c'est bien 12, 12 fois 12= 144
petite chose à savoir c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait quand il y a 2 unités dont y a 2 chiffres qui permettent de retrouver cette unité
par exemple 4 au carré et 6 au carré finissent par la même unité
3 au carré et 7 au carré finissent par la même unité
laquelle choisir?
Pour son résultat
Eh ben c'est très simple c'est grâce à l'encadrement que je vous ai déjà appris que vous allez pouvoir savoir ça.
quand vous encadrez tous ce qu'il y a avant les dizaines, vous savez que vous allez prendre le résultat qui est avant
pour écrire votre résultat donc à quoi sert cette encadrement
tout simplement à voir de quel côté de l'encadrement penche le plus la balance
C'est à dire si, il est plus proche de celui qui est au dessus de lui
ça veut dire que dans votre choix vous aurez à faire vous prendrez le plus grand pour les unités
c'est pas très très clair à expliquer pourtant c'est très facile à comprendre
exemple rapide
avec 1156, si je regarde le chiffre des unités c'est 6.
et il y a 2 carré de chiffre qui finissent par 6 il y a le carré de 4 4x4 16 et il y a le carré de 6 6x6 36. Donc je les note là
maintenant j'oublie ma dizaine je regarde ce qu'il y a avant et j'encadre ça
Donc 11 c'est encadré entre 9 et 16 entre le carré de 3 et le carré de 4
Donc je sais que mon résultat va commencer par un 3 et du coup il fini par quoi 4 ou 6.
Et ben dans mon encadrement 11 c'est plus proche de 9 ou c'est plus proche de 16
C'est plus proche de 9, du plus petit.
Donc je vais prendre la plus petite des 2 possibilités c'est à dire 4.
Et le carré de 34 c'est bien 1156
avec cette méthode vous êtes capable maintenant d'extraire n'importe quelle racine carré jusqu'à la racine carré de 10 000
Franchement ça le fait, c'est à dire que ça peut servir en cours si y a pas la calculatrice
mais aussi je trouve que quand même ça pète un peu en société de savoir extraire une petite racine carré.
à la fin du repas
tranquille
*rire*
je profite de cette vidéo pour répondre aussi globalement à une question que vous me posez un peu partout régulièrement. ça reviens toujours c'est
où est ce que j'ai eu ce boulier là
où est ce que l'on peut trouver un boulier chinois
ça c'est le mien, c'est mon boulier chinois que vous voyez dans toutes mes vidéos.
donc je vais vous mettre dans le descriptif de cette vidéo et de la vidéo 51 qui était la vidéo où je vous apprenais à vous servir facilement d'un boulier
le lien où vous pouvez le trouver
de mémoire celui-ci est à un peu moins de 25euros
mais au moins vous en verrez même d'autres à d'autres prix
si jamais vous galérez à en trouver un
en tout cas pensez bien à prendre "Boulier Chinois" pour avoir cette ligne là.
petite exclu du jour, je vais vous dire ce qu'on va faire comme vidéo samedi
Samedi je vais enfin vous parlez de cold reading
ça fait longtemps que vous me demandez je voulais  prendre le temps de préparer le sujet
je savais pas si j'allais vous en parler en une fois ou en plusieurs fois
il y aura un master class sur le cold reading sur la lecture à froid.
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et n'oubliez pas de laisser le petit pouce en l'air de ce mercredi
le petit pouce en l'air qui va bien. Le fameux *Pouce en l'air*
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonnez à la chaîne si c'est pas déjà fait
Et RDV demain 17h pour le prochain mental vlog
Ciao